[Music]
and our Kelly knew getting a big travel
submitted by Julie from Seattle
hi Julie our Kelly was finally arrested
only to be bailed out by a woman who
still believes he's innocent
damn the powers that he has is crazy you
know what's even crazier than that it's
the fact that he doesn't have enough
guap know for his own being thank you
that's why that it's someone else had a
bill amount you can afford it
let me ask a question ace this would be
super ironic is the chick that bailed
him out also in the surviving series I
don't think so it's another chick that
didn't see the light it just believes in
arcade milk best series to every episode
that [ __ ] could have been done in two
episodes it was so then it was really
good freakin I love the fact that they
had towards the end the girl that they
save the one that he dressed up as a boy
yeah yeah I'm a [ __ ] save their that
was awesome she went back then you live
and then she finally loved to add back
yeah
in the series show I didn't watch the
last episode oh yeah she where I learned
how long it was written and it was like
a date yeah they mentioned it real quick
you might have missed it that's the type
of powers he has that's crazy this game
is crazy how much was his bail a hundred
thousand in that side he can't he
couldn't afford ten thousand no no it
was a million dollar so that birdie he
doesn't have a hundred yo what was that
[ __ ] video that you recorded of him
performing Oh at Sol Sol querías this
music festival I went to and apparently
he does this at all of his shows and he
does this like this bit and he goes he
goes even he starts singing he's all
sweaty and [ __ ] and he has a girl like
wipe and wipe them off oh and then so
he's like he's like and he's singing the
whole time and he's like oh my face and
she's like in the crowd and she's wiping
his face with the top he's like oh I mom
be anything what you did
he's my job he sticks his tongue out
she's
yeah and he goes and he goes keep wiping
it baby and she's doing this everybody
like stands up he's keeping it baby
she's like and she's like rubbing his
dick and then she's like doing this to
his dick you know he's just rubbing it
and he goes and he goes keep it and then
everyone's screaming and he goes and
then he and then everyone's screaming he
goes and he stops he's like you're
trying to take my [ __ ] that was batshit
crazy did you did you see that did you
see that that that showed he did in
Africa David showed me that cuz Jess
children do you have no pants do you
have your shots would you laughs come
with Rob to America why does he have to
be so disgusting because [ __ ] you sold
these hilarious okay you literally
saying he's [ __ ] calling out there do
you have your shots to travel like he
wrote that it oh I got a make sure she
has a tetanus shot so he'd went to the
choir says hey we're gonna do a six-part
harmony harmony do it
do you have tsa PreCheck you know water
bottles in your carry-on so great but
okay we can't watch it anymore go on
yeah but still don't hug it like you
[ __ ] I guarantee you after you watch
this [ __ ] how much are Kelly will you
can you watch the whole traps in the
closet why I love to every bit of it
okay it was [ __ ] awesome
you understand yeah [ __ ] love Spence
I think I think the thing is the way I
watch or like the people that enjoy are
Kelly the way we watch it it's like
another layer to this comedy you're
laughing at his [ __ ] like miserable
life and how delusional he is but when
other people see it all they see is this
[ __ ] destructive
monster and I'm like oh that's too sad
man I mean I thought he would he's like
yeah he's definitely a monster but I
just you know I study was I thought he
was a genius but I mean he still is but
you know I can't play [ __ ] ignition
and my future wedding now I can you
wanted that's all play any more of his
more than a mono stick to the mail and
love you gotta change it you can't even
watch the end of Space Jam huh yeah he
ruined so many memories you can't
separate the artist from the rapist
because he's literally saying the [ __ ]
that he did to women I know so it's hard
to separate it collected because I know
he's disgusting well he's hilarious
you're married to me so you can't why
I'm putting my foot down you can't no
art Kali in our house what about when
I'm working out hey come on that's so
good all right he's so stupid how could
be then flee to Mexico he's not stupid
glad he didn't I know about I'm just
saying like keep it turned himself in 1%
oh he turned himself and he's an
honorable man all my time let her talk
thank you Tim with 10 counts of
aggravated sexual abuse and so there are
four different victims three of them who
were under the age of 17 sorry is this
all the new case because they try to get
him before right no music okay what I
mean that pertains to what we're talking
about though now you're interrupted and
now she can't even give me the thing
okay
great cuz he got he got acquitted over
whatever from the other stuff but yeah
there's just so many late to the madness
you quit it quit it
okay she was [ __ ] acquitted in bucket
it because there was too much
information the cultures coming up
finally I know a little bit
I know [ __ ] cigarettes and eat wave
anyway yeah so one of the people that
are going after him one of the attorneys
he says that he has a video of our Kelly
having sex with another 14 mm yes and
like they're painting on each other body
this time again yes
and during this sex tape he's they're
both talking about her 14 year old [ __ ]
ah why did we have to note the age in
the video tape he's so dumb would you
ever see that that boondocks episode of
boondocks
so this that's where it was the are
Kelly Chow and they're watching the tape
and the lawyer is like there's no way
you can't even tell that this is our
Kelly then he get to the camera through
the hole on the mirror are you just the
focus real quick and then they're like
that could be that could be a look like
that dead doesn't mean SR Kelly in in
the in the cartoon you get to that he
gets up on Kasich hello oh yes this is
Robert Kelly yes oh you need my social
security number yes basically what that
is say your name baby say how old you
are 14 oh and that's that's the time
that makes it even like super gross and
[ __ ] up right because then you know
it's that that turns him on a little
[ __ ] what's a 14 year old dude yeah
Kelly what are so gross they smell like
the 14 euro exactly shout-out to the 14
year olds oh sorry they have a smell -
we've been 14 and gross yeah one day you
won't be gross but at 14 you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're doing you smell and
you're weird at 14 I was gross
Cortinas gross everywhere even a 14 year
old dogs kind of nasty my grandpa
oh gosh now I feel pretty good at 14
yeah you know who else should be like
put to prison - is this whole team and
everyone that created this world for him
so I read something that I read that if
he gets convicted off of this right then
then his team might be liable I think so
because he's in a bubble he thinks it's
okay right and and every time he wins
every time he keeps like beating the law
and then surviving and doing whatever
the [ __ ] he wants like now he has his
god complex if nothing can stop him he's
not even in the same like mental playing
field as everybody he should he should
actually be taken to an asylum like most
people that aren't in the same world as
us he's like [ __ ] batshit crazy so
we're gonna [ __ ] up people in his
circle right I read that this this other
tape got leaked um by a family member of
the girl because our Kelly stopped
paying yeah that family members so then
he was like I'm gonna leak the tape now
oh stop being hush money yeah yeah he
was holding on
well that docu-series was fascinating
because it should have been called
[ __ ] I knew everything because
everybody knew everything yeah and it
was in there like calling them out now
yeah it's so funny because they would
talk about it as if they were victims
themselves right so they were sitting in
there and they go well he goes well I
just about had enough and I had to say
something
thirty years later everyone was going
either for his money for his attention
for his you know like talent everything
yeah I mean he was in a position though
where he could be a predator mm-hmm and
it's not like I don't want to make it
seem like like it's the girls fall in
anyway because there's always gonna be
fan fangirls right and it's it's his
responsibility to not take advantage of
that right right but they also wanted
his attention really bad and they you
know like what difference between like
when you're when you're [ __ ] like a
grown grew be you know it's like okay ya
know that you want you're a that was
like 20-something years old I would I
didn't really have somebody for her like
getting involved or Kelly but it's like
but there's no one that was like
30-something yeah yeah exactly but when
you're like we hate you when you're in
that position of power and you're
praying on like
young as girls were still like you know
kind of growing up and yeah it's super
yeah they're impressionable yeah cuz
they'll listen to any adult or authority
figure so like yeah he's still taking
he's still [ __ ] [ __ ] up but at the
same time there are other adults there
that knew that even helped him get the
girls that would like chase down the
girls that he was like I like that girl
because they kept getting paid they were
on the payroll all that [ __ ] everybody
is responsible but the way that they're
just making this one guy come out to be
like this demon he didn't he woke up
this way that that was created by that
group he got booty rape too right by his
own family members that's one that was
created dude it was by a lady right no
his uncle multiple yeah cuz there's this
one thing what the [ __ ] everybody just
tag-teamed him like he was just his
whole brother's too he would like the
neighborhood butthole yeah like no cuz
his little brother remember these little
brother was like he got raped by their
uncle and then he went up to art Kelly
he was that hey uncle did this to me or
whatever and he's like no he did it no
he didn't even though our Kelly was
getting raped by him too hmm yeah that's
sad that was in the news in the series
brother yeah I was laughing too hard
that was kind of sad part was like
harder laughing I was laughing because
of how ridiculous his brother in jail
was he did the Michael Jackson
impression voice that was so unnecessary
because good you know Michael Jesse's
like do it bro you don't have to do that
in jail you little Uzi and he has the
[ __ ] my ice blue eye contacts his [ __ ]
up weird dude yeah
[Music]